Let's go next to our caller from the sick.
So three area code six.
So three could really go either way because
I think six.
So three is New Hampshire, where you have,
you know, live free or die and you have all
sorts of different things.
Who's calling today from six 00 three?
Hello, this is Adam.
I haven't really been out too much, but there's
been way more and way more biting science
than I thought there would be in New Hampshire,
you're saying?
Yes.
All right, that's good.
So my question, if I have a minute, is I was
wondering like.
If we should expand our use of government,
because I think we mostly refer to government
as the federal government, like with with
land in a flag.
But I would argue if libertarians want their
way and they want to reduce the power of the
federal government, it's big government.
If a government is the authority with the
most power, if you reduce that power, there's
is I would argue that there would be.
You would give the government data to a private
company because then they would have the most
power and you would just be governed by a
different set of sort of a public entity,
a more private entity.
OK.
Beautiful.
I don't know that I 100 percent understand
what you're saying, but I think you're getting
to two important things that that are that
are crucial.
One is a lot of these libertarian pipe dreams
or wet dreams or whatever you want to call
these things, OK?
They really are just replacing government
as a regulatory body with whichever guy gets
the most guns the fastest and uses those guns
to take control of something.
And I don't know that we're better off with
that.
Sam Ceder has some really great calls with
libertarians talking about this.
And then number two, sometimes you'll hear
from these small government libertarians that
you simply don't need an apparatus so large
as a federal government or even a state government
in some cases.
The reality is that when you have multi-billion
dollar transnational companies, trillion dollar
companies, etc, you only the power of of sometimes
multiple federal governments across the world.
Only that power can actually regulate corporations
that large.
And Adam, I'm going to let you go because
it sounds so loud where you are, but I really
do appreciate the question.
Good answer.
All right.
No problem.
Adam from New Hampshire, seeing the New Hampshire
Biden signs.
That's good.
I think pointing out the folly of some libertarian
arguments, that's also very good.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we're
taking a really quick break and we're going
right back to the phones.